[Music]
every year the home of the American auto
industry also hosts the industry's most
important car show
daring designs and new technology will
be on display at the North American
International Auto Show which kicks off
today joining us with a preview of what
we'll see is mark Takahashi senior
automotive writer for edmonds mark good
morning good morning welcome before we
started talking about the future let us
talk a little bit about the past yes how
was 2017 for the industry 2017 was a
strong year but we were 1.8 percent down
from the record set in 2016
that said we're still selling well over
17 million cars that's very healthy we
are predicting a little bit of a dip for
2018 but considering what I'm seeing
coming out of Detroit right now it might
break even you're headed to the Detroit
Auto Show at right after this broadcast
I am how important is this event for the
auto industry it is really important
this is the biggest show for us not just
in the US but it's a big show
internationally as well think of it as
maybe the Oscars for the automotive
industry it's where the North American
car of the year as well as utility and
truck are announced so it's a big awards
deal but it's also the show where a lot
of the manufacturer of rolling out cards
that we're expecting to see not just
these pie-in-the-sky concepts okay so
speaking of that what what are the big
trends that we're looking for for 2018
trucks trucks trucks trucks so the f-150
is still the sales leader by a
considerable margin that said Chevy is
gonna roll out their competitor the
Silverado at the Detroit Show actually
it's already been shown and the RAM 1500
which is the other truck in the category
is also going to be shown the Ford
Ranger is kind of a revival we haven't
seen a ranger in the u.s. in a long time
but it's been sold overseas for quite
some time and in addition to the Ranger
on the very high end of that Mercedes
after 40 years Mercedes is rolling out a
new g-class the big G wagon you can see
it on screen right there you
part of it on yeah because reading
through setting up a lot of said yeah
it's a teaser shot but it on the outside
it looks very similar to the big boxy
g-wagen we see today but it should drive
much better than its predecessor all
right let's talk new technology because
GM announced yesterday that they're
rolling out a car in 2019 without a
steering wheel gas and brake pedals yes
the Cruze av AV for autonomous vehicle
now 2019 is very ambitious maybe a
little over ambitious because the
legislation hasn't caught up to
technology yet they're not allowed for
public consumption just yet they're
still being tested in select states in
certain regions but as much as I love
driving I'm looking forward to
autonomous vehicles mmm I'm scared of
autonomous vehicles Marc as my mom I'm
putting my mom hat on what happens if
something goes wrong is there an
emergency override in their vehicles
there's most definitely going to be some
sort of panic button or override where
if things aren't working the way they
should hit the button should pull right
over and stop yeah it you're not just
along for the ride at least for the B
for the beginning stages of autonomy all
right well there's a lot to love and see
at this Auto Show and you're getting on
a plane to go to Detroit right after
this Marc gachi thank you for dropping
the knowledge before you leave you're
very fun at the Oscars of the car show
thank you very much